hello uh is anyone there can you hear me
who is this I'm I'm a security
researcher from Canada someone's leaked
a password that you use somewhere else
what password is it if you don't mind
sharing um I can't quite pronounce the
email but it was a and the password was
damn that's actually insane like are you
able to see where I live and everything
I don't know where you live right now
but if someone was really that dedicated
I mean yeah they could they could
geolocate an IP they could see when
you're not home so you think just Chang
my password on the nest or what yeah if
you go on Google and you Google have I
been pwned uh you'll see like anywhere
that your password was leaked and what
info was leaked also if you want to
follow our Facebook page I I I don't
know if you have Facebook or not but
it's Anonymous Calgary Canada all right
well yeah thank you for letting me know
and uh yeah appreciate
it